[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm gonna answer a question from
one of my newsletter readers Joe who's
an insurance agent pretty new to the
business and is having a hard time
getting out there making sales apart
from his blood relatives and was running
what my advice would be to help him grow
his business so Joe you're in a tough
industry lots of competition and there's
very little that separates the products
that different insurance agents will
sell so the first thing that you need to
do is come up with your unique value
proposition and what this basically is
is explaining what makes you different
so you're not just Joe the average
everyday Joe salesperson you are XYZ so
what makes you different from everybody
else and when you introduce yourself you
have to put that in your statement to
make everybody know that you are the
insert' insurance agent who helps these
types of people so you can differentiate
yourself on the service they provide and
also going after a specific target
market that's different than everybody
else so as an example you know everybody
wants to go after the high net worth
individuals and people are going to take
out the big policies that doesn't really
help you so much what I would do is try
to target people who have specific
interests and learn about them tailor
solutions to help them come up with
other packages that you've seen work
with that type of age group and
demographics and then be able to sell
into them you can also use shared
interests so example if you are a huge
baseball fan and you love the Cleveland
Indians part of what you could do is
take people to the games
who you know when the Cleveland Indians
are in town and you can go out to
customers who also like the Cleveland
Indians so it's a lot easier for you to
connect with them and it's a lot more
fun to do business so you're not just
going after anybody and everybody who
needs an insurance agent you're going
after the people who are ideal clients
for you and you love working with and
you have shared shared passions with so
identifying first you know your unique
value proposition who is Joe the
insurance guy what do you do that's
different everybody else and then start
defining who
your customers are so I would try to be
as specific as you can with that you
obviously don't want to limit yourself
off and say you know only people who
like to clip in Indians and who are you
know 50 to 55 and men right there might
be a little specific but you want to do
try to define your target market as much
as you can with your customer base so
look at your age group look at look at
interest look at their stage in life
look at what some of their needs are and
build up a profile the ideal person that
you want to target and from there if you
can specialize in those people and you
go and you tell them when you're meeting
with them that you specialize with those
types of people and you can show how
you've helped people who are like them
the more like they don't want to sign up
with you instead of I'm Joe and I sell
insurance to anybody and everybody right
it's a lot harder to make that kind of
sale so you may be turning away business
that you can make some money from but
are not ideal clients and then focus on
the ones who are great potential clients
for you because you know you can service
your needs
from there once I can a clearly
explained why I'm different and I can
explain the type of customers that I
want to go after then you can start with
your marketing strategy
and for you I try to look at events to
start so it's a very personal business
if I'm gonna work with an insurance
agent I want to know that again he
understands my needs likes what I'm
about I can relate to him really well
and so events are great way to do that
you're meeting people again you know we
want to treat your finding events where
your target customers are hanging out at
so it's a great way to make those first
connections
I would then look to get in front of
connectors so potential referral
partners who can you partner up with
where you prefer them business they
queer for you business I look to get
into the local media you want to be seen
as the local expert for insurance for
you know whatever age group again
whoever your target customers are and
pitching the media is a lot easier when
you have your unique value proposition
and you know who you're targeting is
your customers and you have a story to
be able to tell instead of just I'm Joe
the sales guy right so getting the media
local media especially we can have some
kind of ongoing relationship if you're
writing a monthly column for example in
your local media could really help
I then think about creating content and
for here you'd want to be creating
articles and other types of content that
again are geared towards your target
customer educating them creating a
monthly newsletter that goes out that
you also post on your website so giving
them ongoing useful helpful content that
talks about where the right with their
stage of life that might be able to you
might be able to help them with and new
products or services that you're coming
out with that again could be able to
help them and then I'd also create video
and if somebody is meeting you in an
event or they heard about you through
the media or the read one of your
articles a great way to introduce
yourself again is through video
especially if you haven't met them yet
and it's coming to a connector or media
another source people again this is a
very personal business for you people
will make decisions really quickly based
on seeing you and hearing you so if you
create a quick video of yourself that
goes up on your website when people land
they're able to learn a little bit about
you kind of see what you like what
you're about again you're talking about
these two things your unique value
proposition and types of customers you
like to deal with and it goes a long way
to be able to make a warm welcome online
when you haven't actually met somebody
face-to-face and when I first started my
business my website is off my name so
seven Carl calm I kind of hid behind my
content and we did a lot of profiles the
famous entrepreneurs and people started
writing in asking about me and who I was
and eventually I started creating more
and more content and got into video as
well and people seem to really like the
videos and it's a great way of people to
kind of get to know me and I've have
people come up to me and feel like they
already know me because they watch other
videos and they've seen all of them and
they know our regular viewers and you
know I don't know them yet but it's
great to meet them so you can have the
same relationship where people can come
to your site quickly watch your intro
video see you're a nice guy see that you
understand their needs and your catering
just to them and they'll start forming a
relationship with you even though you
haven't really set a relationship with
them yet so they're more opportune more
likely to pick up the phone I want to
call you so hope that helps so again
come up be unique value proposition what
makes you different identify who your
target customers are in as much detail
as you can then start your marketing
strategy through events going after
connector
get into the media create a content
strategy and creating some video as well
Joe I hope that's useful if you guys
like the video please leave a comment
below and it also always appreciate it
when you want to leave a thumbs up for
the videos so thank you and we'll see
you on the next episode
[Music]
you